[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
matt liner analyst for uh fox big noon
kickoff uh of course the heisman trophy
winner uh he's part of fox's on-site
pre-game show in indy iowa and michigan
on saturday night and that'll be for the
big ten championship
matt how are you not a lot to talk about
in the world of college football huh
dan um first of all i'm doing good and
did i just walk into you not liking
fireball shots is that is that what i
heard yes yes you did i'm going to well
i i mean
you let let's have a drink we'll take a
few of those down i'm a big fireball guy
yeah but see i i would just rather do
you know whiskey or something like that
yeah i mean look i'm not mad at you um
but yeah i mean how about how about how
about this week i mean just uh i i don't
think it's ever we've ever seen a week
like this in college football with just
obviously
the amount of money that's being shelled
out for these coaches just the the big
jobs the big coaches
um obviously i'm ecstatic which i know
we're going to talk about but um and
then and then just you know championship
saturday championship weekend i mean
there's some big games and um still a
lot of you know a handful of scenarios
to see who gets into the top four so
yeah it's been a wild year in college
football it's been a great year in
college football uh you know we've been
on the road almost every week which has
been a lot of fun and again but real
quick before we get into this i'm a
little jealous because every week i see
my buddy bq on with you brady yeah um
and i just you know i just give me a
little more love dp you want me to get
on more you know i got to watch my notre
dame guy i've been calling
we've been calling
we've asked for the am i
and my buddy mclovin is there shout out
to mclovin what's up matt
matt and i would do fireball shots
together dan
that's right yeah like you know brady is
a little too pretty for this show so
you're more of a man's man but you know
we've reached out
and they say nope uh he's not available
he's not available yeah i need to i need
to talk to somebody then all right yeah
and look i'll blow right by brady quinn
i mean he never won a heisman
i appreciate that man all right um
if i told you a week ago usc was hiring
lincoln riley
notre dame was going to lose brian kelly
to lsu
and michigan was going to be to ohio
state which one would you have said that
ain't happening
uh probably lincoln riley to usc i mean
that was really and again i'm more you
know obviously a little more invested in
that and i didn't see any of them
happening the only one to be honest with
you
that i thought had a shot was michigan
now i picked ohio state and and i
thought they were going to win but
that you know this team and and
obviously now talking about in hindsight
this team is is just different than it's
been in the past and they went out and
proved that but um yeah the one the one
that shocked me the most was my alma
mater and it shocked me in a great way
obviously but
um you know that weekend i was hearing a
lot of chatter about
potentially matt campbell yeah and i was
getting ready you know kind of just to
all right get on board he's a really
good football coach be happy with him
um but then i get a text um on sunday
from from my buddy bruce feldman who i
know you know well and
he says lincoln riley and i said holy
hell are you kidding me
and
i had i had
i had talked to a few people prior the
weeks off dude saying that he would
he the only job that he would
potentially take was usc but i was like
there's no way i mean
you know and then all of a sudden it
happened and i and i couldn't be i mean
gosh dan it's it's that's what sc needs
they needed that splash they needed
someone who can change the culture there
can you know it's just it's just it's a
home run higher in every sense of the
word um ufc is relevant immediately um
he's already flipping a ton of recruits
i was just looking at some of these
recruits this morning he's already he's
already getting some guys that were
interested in ohio state now they want
to go to usc like he he's he's hitting
the ground running and i couldn't be
more happy you know to be a trojan and
that he's the next head coach head coach
there
it's never uh done in a delicate way
it's hard to do that it feels like
there's there's outrage nationally that
brian kelly left notre dame there's not
outrage for lincoln riley leaving
oklahoma but because notre dame's
polarizing is there a tactful way for a
coach to leave if you were a player and
you played for notre dame and brian
kelly comes back from a recruiting trip
and says guys gather at 7 00 a.m i'm
taking the lsu job
how would you feel
yeah i mean it's it's
it's hard because
the one thing with notre dame is
i mean they're still they're still a
very realistic path they get into the
playoffs i mean can you imagine they get
into the playoff and the narrative
around that without brian kelly i mean
it's so so that's the weird thing about
that is just like
these players are right there in a
position either going to a new year six
bowl or or a realistic shot not a lot
has to happen for them to sneak into the
top four
and then all of a sudden you
your coach is is taking a job and three
hours later he's saying bye in two
minutes and he's out and then obviously
you know the story out there of going
out recruiting
and then that that news kind of breaking
right after that and his whole staff is
out recruiting so
um is there a tactful way you know i'm
sure he could have probably handled it a
little bit better but
in this day and age with the you know
the early signing period and and the
amount of money that has just being i
mean it's a hundred million dollars and
and you look at you or you look at
excuse me lsu
and and i by the way brian kelly's a is
a damn good football coach he's one of
the best in the business
um but you look at the position you know
the the situation lsu the way they can
recruit there
um they won a title just a couple of
years ago and then you dangle out
you dangle out nine figures or whatever
it is ten figure whatever it is nine
figures and it's hard to pass up so yeah
look i think it's part of the business
it's unfortunate and uh it's the way i
mean lincoln you know lincoln their
season was done they did it right after
but even that happened within within
hours you know and all of a sudden these
players are like hey wait what what
about me like what happened here so do
you think brian kelly would have left if
notre dame was ranked third
uh yeah okay i do yeah i do i i think
i think he saw the money um i think he
you know obviously from from talking to
a few people and just reading the
stories out there obviously there's some
things that you know maybe he wanted
there that didn't happen over time
um but
then again you know he did hit the
ceiling there i mean he did he he got
them to the playoffs multiple times it's
just there's a gap between notre dame
and alabama's and ohio states and
clemsons of the world
and you know he just i think he took
them as far as he could possibly take
them and then you look at a job like lsu
with with the talent that's available
even the talent on that roster i mean
it's still a very talented roster
um you know that there's an opportunity
for him to win the national championship
there but yeah it's
look it's it's kind of the way this the
whole college football is set up with
you know the the early signing period
and these call these coaches jumping i
mean lincoln riley
was introduced monday which i was at the
press conference that night he's out
recruiting already down in orange county
in southern california i mean that's how
fast this is happening there's no time
to look in the mirror so
um but unfortunately dad as you said you
know the players are the one that that
suffer from that did notre dame recruit
they did not they did not recruit me
i i think at the time so at the time
they were
it was ty willingham they were they had
a lot more of the you know they had
quarterbacks that could move
and that's not me i think they had a
carlisle holiday i remember if carlisle
holiday was a good player for them
actually my teammate in arizona um he
ended up playing a receiver for us in
their league but
um i don't think i was a good enough
athlete for them at the time mclovin
said you didn't have the academics to
get in matt
and that's probably true as well
listen i was i was a social major at usc
and i took ballroom dancing my last year
so i remember people people gave you so
much grief for that i remember having
you on talking to you about that
but here's here's the thing people need
to realize i'd already graduated i just
had to i had to take two units just to
be eligible for my senior year so how
about this my whole senior year which
was just incredible and and again i came
back because i wanted to be at usc and
all of those things i took two units
because i had already graduated so
people are up and over i'm like i was
either that or an art class i'm like all
right i'll take ballroom dancing this
could be fun it was tuesday nights
once a week
during the fall
so my my schedule was just all football
one night a week actually you know who i
took that class with mark sanchez was in
that class and no one and mark sanchez
was a true freshman so he took it i
think as an elective or whatever at the
time and nobody ripped mark sanchez for
taking ballroom dancing yeah i know man
it's all right i had a i i think i got
an a minus in the class too so you know
and you probably good place to meet
women
uh
yeah you know i don't remember to be
honest with you i'm not sure i'm not
sure
i don't even know how many people were
in that class but
um
yeah i mean listen i didn't take a lot
of that with me post usc you know i i
couldn't do the two step right now with
the box step and you asked me
uh before uh i say goodbye uh how does
iowa beat michigan in this game this uh
saturday night on fox
yeah look this is uh this is
it's a yeah like it's not a trap game i
mean this is a conference championship
game iowa's a really good football team
but one of the interesting things the
way i was built and the way they've won
this year is is takeaways on defense and
again that's that's a very common thing
you know hey if you get turnovers all
that you're going to win a lot of games
but the way it is for them is
30 30 percent of iowa scoring has come
off a takeaways iowa and i'm sure you
know this is just they're not built to
go 80 90 yard drives it's not the type
of offense they have they have fed off
of
their defense being outstanding at
creating turnovers because it gives them
short fields and that's how they've
operated that's how they won a lot of
games the two losses this year they had
one takeaway so
if michigan
just protects the ball which they've
done all season long it's going to be
very challenging for iowa to just to
just drive and score enough points
that's just not how they're built so
that's just something to keep an eye on
in this game is
when iowa is opportunistic on defense
which they are very good defense
otherwise then they're going to have a
shot to win this game but look they i
think michigan is
mission michigan is legit they're very
very good
they have their identity they got those
bad boys up front on defense hutchinson
and jabba who are very good players
first round guys
haskins is a stud it's going to be tough
for iowa but you never
kirk ference and the job he does and
that team you can just never count those
guys out so it'll be it could be a low
scoring fist fight but it'll be a good
game
safe travels matt great to have you on
again and uh thanks for joining us
dan thanks for having me buddy
madeline analyst for fox big noon
kickoff yeah we'll kick brady quinn at
the curb
i mean he doesn't have a heisman